[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
pour ce nouveau numéro de vip
aujourd'hui je reçois un jeune auteur
c'est son premier roman salle bourges
nicolas rodier bonjour bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
virtuelle sur le plateau de tv soixante
dix huit pour ce vip vous venez de
sortir un roman il fait partie de la
rentrée littéraire c'est un premier
roman chez flammarion son titre comme je
disais à l'heure c'est sale bouge et
pourquoi être venu à l'écriture à 38 ans
chez un monsieur est ce que c'était
quelque chose ans l'attend chez vous oui
ça fait longtemps que j'avais envie
d'écrire c'est vrai que j'ai fait des
études de philosophie j'ai fait
hypokhâgne khâgne donc j'avais une
attirance pour les lettres et la culture
en général
et puis bah après des vaines tentatives
autour de la vingtaine je me suis remis
autour de 35 ans c'était un projet qui
me tenait vraiment à coeur
d'accord et alors vous avez choisi un
cadre bien particulier à savoir le cadre
de la ville de versailles le votre héros
pierre c'est appartient à une famille
catholique bonne bourgeoisie vieille
famille ce qu'on appelle vite fait les
milieux privilégiés
on en reparlera après de ses privilèges
et donc il est l'aîné de six enfants
mais ce n'est pas vous c'est pas moi et
c'est en même temps un peu moi moi je
pense qu'en littérature ce dont on parle
le mieux c'est ce qu'on connaît un peu
donc il ya toute une partie du cadre
social et culturel j'ai envie de dire de
ce roman qui correspond à ce que j'ai pu
observer dans mon enfance et mon
adolescence alors je suis pas de
versailles
j'ai fait une année d'études à
versailles gagne à la bruyère oui mais
j'étais de saint-cloud alors bon on est
à une dizaine de kilomètres médias blu
ray de
d'accord donc c'est quand même d'aider
des gens c'est un milieu celle que vous
connaissez que vous avez côtoyé par des
amis des cousins et c'est donc pourquoi
avoir choisi de placer votre héros
pierre dans dans ce milieu là parce que
déjà avant avant d'oublier salle
bourgeat c'est une injure que vous-même
avait déjà reçu reçu
oui mais entre bourges donc c'est très
bon j'appelle relatif oui c'était dur
qui c'est notre poche donc voilà
maintenant c'est plutôt une crainte est
une hantise d'être perçue en tout cas là
je parle personnellement comme ça
pendant mon enfance et mon adolescence
c'est une réalité de perçu comme un seul
bourges et puis après sur l'aspect plus
de la fiction serait intéressant que ce
soit le finalement l'image et le miroir
que garde le personnage de lui même mais
une injure ça le principe d' enfermer
finalement c'est c'est quelque chose qui
l'enferment de se percevoir comme ça
d'accord et alors donc est ce qu'on peut
parler du problème du déterminisme de
dans votre roman en fait vous démarrez
un peu par la fin bien se retrouve en
garde à vue je crois ou en procès parce
qu'il a été violent envers sa femme
et il s'interroge sur cette violence
dont il n'arrive pas à se défaire une
violence qu'il ait subi lui-même toute
son enfance et son adolescence
est ce que c'est on peut dire que c'est
le coeur du sujet de votre roman se
déterminer mais c'est comme ça que je
l'abordé je voulais vraiment faire un
livre sur le conditionnement qu'ils
soient sociales vrai dire familiale et
le point important pour moi c'était de
surtout d'avoir un texte d une histoire
qui montre la difficulté de s'en
extraire
trop souvent je pense que d'ailleurs et
ses propres du conditionnement on pense
qu'on est émancipé ou libérés mais comme
on dit conditionné on le voit pas il ya
un an penser on reste conditionnelle on
s'en rend pas compte
et moi je voulais avoir ce portrait un
peu tragique d'un personnage qui
essayent de s'extirper de son
conditionnement mais j'ai envie de dire
dans son cas il a été tellement ancrée
en lui que ça en est très très difficile
et finalement c'est la bonne nouvelle
même si elle est peu perceptible mais
c'est qu'ils aient une tierce personne
une trajectoire haute qui est le
personnage de mode
qui finalement disant stop et en portant
plainte ouvre une baer une brèche je
pense pour la remise en cause du
personnage donc vous voyez c'est
possible oui je pense que dans la vie il
ya des rencontres des trajectoires des
expériences des hasards on a tous la
possibilité à des moments où des ou un
autre de de faire bifurquer et d'influer
sur notre trajectoire mais la pire des
choses pour rester conditionné c'est de
croire qu'on l'ait pas y croire qu'on
élit but qu'on n'est pas conditionné
france oui donc là il ya une belle prise
de conscience est d'ailleurs le ya une
scène pas de torture mais presque qui
qui ouvre votre livre on voit l'enfant
c'est l'après midi devant son décès de
carottes râpées et malgré les claque
assénée régulièrement qu'il n'arrive pas
à avaler
et ça pour lui c'est c'est presque
normal son cousin on lui a fait la même
chose son cousin il s'est retrouvé la
tête éclatée contre l'assiette est ce
que c'est c'est terrible tout se sait
non dits ces acceptations ses codes
malgré le mal qu'ils puissent faire tout
le monde accepte c'est comme ça c'est ce
que vous avez ressenti aussi bas je
pense que alors là est le premier thème
pour moi c'était conditionnement
familiale d'un certain milieu et le
deuxième c'était celui de la violence
est une chose dont je suis persuadé
c'est que la pratique d'une violence
elle est liée à sa banalisation c'est à
dire que les parents ou la mer le
personnage de mère quand elle à elle
elle est devenue mère à aucun moment
elle s'est dit qu'elle allait pratiquer
de la violence envers ses enfants de
manière consciente et pourtant elle le
fait parce que je pense qu'il ya une
forme de d'ameublement avoir la violence
et de manière générale d'app sont d une
forme d' aveuglement avoir été violentée
dans l'exergue puis on répète ce qu'on a
subi ça se fait dans celle ci on le
répète c'est qu'on s'en rend pas
forcément compte je pense
d'un certain point de vue et je pense
que cette banalisation bas elle est
autant chez les enfants que chez les
parents puisque c'est un mode de vie
sain système on se pose pas de question
d'accord et il ya un autre thème qui
revient souvent et et on a l'impression
que le héros il a honte de son milieu
social et on se moque de sa mère
beaucoup d aspects physiques qui
remarquent ces femmes qui ont eu des tas
d'enfants fin 6 5
être enfant sur la plage elles ont les
jambes plein de varices il a quand même
pas mal de recul et la honte c'est assez
récurrent dans ce livre est ce que le
piège est là il a honte de son milieu on
de ses frères et soeurs ou pas pour moi
c'est un des facteurs d'explication de
son inhibition de sa difficulté
finalement à avancer c'est qu'il a
profondément honte et le problème de la
honte aussi sait qui il accorde trop
d'importance peut être aussi au regard
des autres ou au regard qu'on porte sur
son milieu et finalement ça c'est
peut-être un des écueils de pierre mais
c'est sûr c'est que la honte conditionne
une grande partie de la représentation
qu'il est lui-même d'accord et est ce
que je sais pas aussi à force d'avoir
été donc finalement très souvent
humiliées psychologiquement ou
physiquement dans son éducation qui fait
qu' il arrive au bout d'un moment il la
moindre remarque négative que lui fait
ça à son épouse mots de la grèce comme
si c'était quelque chose de très grave
ce qu'il n'est pas du coup devenus sans
cesse à fleur de peau et ce qui
expliquerait aussi ses réactions
violentes et 10 est disproportionnée à
bassens oui c'est exactement ça je pense
quand même qu'il ya une estime de lui
qui était très faible et que finalement
il a tellement été offensés et humilié
quelque part dans son enfance que après
il reste dans ce système de l'enfance
est le point de départ de la colère ou
de le de la violence c'est c'est
fondamentalement je pense l'offensé on
se met en colère ou en violence qu'on se
croit aux français le problème c'est que
son radar il est complètement biaisé ils
sont pensés pour pas grand chose en fait
et ça c'est lié un d'estimé de soi qui a
été brisé je pense dans son enfance pour
le personnage de pierre ou comme s'il
avait atteint son quota quand il
supporte plus son côté by supporte plus
du tout et puis là sur l'estimé de soi
qui est complètement brisée s'est
exacerbée dans ce roman mais pour le
coup c'est une marque mois que ceux
observés dans le milieu bourgeois
conservateur à tendances cathodiques
avec lequel j'ai évolué je pense quand
même que
il ya toute une approche éducative pour
caricaturer cap a fait 68 ou mêmes qui
critiquent 68 mais qui est quand même
dans l'oeuf dans le dos voilà dans le
carcan et non dans le comment dire le
l'étouffement de désirs individuels et
alors pourquoi est ce que ces gens
tiennent tellement à à respecter ses
codes à se retrouver être tous pareils
ils ont peur de quoi en fait
bah en fait je pense que c'est on est
structuré tous comme ça d'une certaine
manière
pardon appartenait la volonté
d'appartenir à un troupeau quel qu'il
soit oui mais en fait c'est une histoire
d'estimé de soi je pense aussi et c'est
ce qui leur procure de la dignité ce qui
leur procure de la dignité c'est de se
retrouver dans des codes c'est très
précis autour de leur positionnement
social de leur histoire de leur identité
et donc ça je pense qu'on est tous à
vouloir s'y attacher maintenant ils les
gens s'y attache avec beaucoup plus de
virulence dans certains cas mais je
pense que le terreau de tout ça c'est
une mauvaise estime de soi
d'accord et alors comment faire comme
comme vous on décide de faire des études
qui ne sont pas dans l'est dans la
normalité dans ces milieux là vous vous
avez voulu faire de la philo votre héros
c'est la même chose on le on encourage
absolument pas on n'attend pas ça de lui
et est ce que comme on peu se rebeller
avoir la force de dire non moi je
souffrais philo je ne ferai pas
ingénieur je ne serai pas à hec ou
médecin quand on est les deux alors ça
c'est effectivement quelque chose qui
était important pour moi d'insuffler sa
dans la fiction et dans le personnage de
pierre puisque je l'expérimenté un
certain point de vue c'est vrai que
c'est amusant avec le recul à quel point
ça pouvait susciter une angoisse que ne
pas faire dans certains milieux des
grandes études ou en tout cas des études
qui sont pas voué à un avenir financier
à peu près correct dans leur esprit
voilà maintenant
c'est difficile c'est très difficile
prendre un exemple un peu simpliste mais
quand on regarde facebook - c'est avec
frappé à ma génération tout le monde
avait plein de militaires un temps à 25
ans tout le monde se met dans le rang et
on voit tout le monde a fait les mêmes
études
le continent le conditionnement social
c'est vraiment une des choses les plus
puissantes comme déterminisme d'accord
vous avez sorti bas nous forcément nom
est forcément aussi un peu mieux encore
beaucoup de choses à mon avis j'essaye
de les traquer au quotidien de ne pas
être dans un autre est d'avoir
conscience de deux de mes privilèges et
de la violence que kiki qu'ils
engendrent dans le monde malgré moi
d'accord et malgré tout vous enfin je
dis pas que p assé voué à la fin du
livre d'ailleurs vous remercier vos
parents pourquoi pas parce que justement
je suis pas fier et que si jules espace
dans ma vie pour écrire ce livre c'est
que mes parents laisser à ces tests pour
décrire mon accord donc on peut en
réchapper et tous les tous les parents
ne sont pas ne sont pas complètement
comme ça même dans ce milieu là vous
avez un projet de prochain livre
commence à y travailler oui mais il faut
quand il faut
avec plaisir là je voudrais parler je
pense du conditionnement politique de
mon milieu
d'accord on reste dans les
conditionnements et le déterminisme
écoutez c'est passionnant je recommande
à tout le monde la lecture de ce livre
salle bourges toi-même j'ai envie de
dire
et voilà on découvre plein de choses et
ces milieux soi-disant priviligié ne le
sont finalement pas tant que ça voilà
nicolas odier à bientôt j'espère merci
beaucoup et personnels ou pour ce
prévenu nous pour le prochain livre avec
plaisir a très vite merci beaucoup au
revoir à tous merci de nous avoir suivis
il
[Musique]